And this is another quiz where of course we
haven't already given you the answer.
Hopefully you had to think about it a little bit.
The answer is that you want to do stemming before you do the bag of
words representation and that's for two reasons.
The first one is if you put it in the bag of words representation before you
stem then there's kind of no point in stemming because you could get
the same word repeated many times within your bag of words representation.
You're not really like condensing the information in any useful way.
In fact, you're probably making it noisier and worse.
because you'll just have the word sponse in there six times.
Also it's more technically feasible to apply stemming first and
then put it in the bag of words representation.
Because stemming is going to assume a string.
And the bag of words representation is going to look like some kind of
matrix that has many different documents and, and words within those documents.
So you almost always want to do stemming as one of
the first steps in your text processing.
You go through and you stem each word and then put it into
the representation that you'll use in your machine learning algorithm.